nous ouvrons ce journal avec l'ouragan
katrina qui pourrait être la plus grosse
tempête a touché le pays
l'entraîneur de dender de ce qu'il faut
juste une autre cause 2010
nous faut de l'aide on arrive au bund au
réseau d'eau de nourriture tiendra plus
très longtemps ne peut rien faire de
plus pour eux si ce n'est rendre ça le
moins pénible au possible
je vous assure que chacun d'entre nous a
fait du mieux qu'il pouvait et toutes
les personnes qui étaient dans cet
hôpital ont été traités avec dignité ils
ont trouvé 45 cadavres vous trouvez ça
normal
45 patients morts
étant donné les conditions on peut
décemment dire que c'était évitable ça
ça reste à voir